Obviously if you want to minimize training time,
training once is faster than training ten times.
So it's obviously TRAIN/TEST is, is, is probably the better one to choose.
If you just want to minimize run time,
well in each case you end up picking one machine running algorithm.
I would then say if you just care about minimize run time,
you might as well get the benefit of 10-fold Cross Validation,
to have a better assessment of what's going on.
So I would put my cross-mark over here, but
it's not clear this, either one could be correct.
But if you want to maximize accuracy of your assessment, how good your algorithm
is, you definitely go for the penalty of going into 10-fold Cross Validation.
Take the extra time and you will get a better result.